etonnant non bonjour nous avons voulu
cette semaine donner la parole à une
minorité agréable et intéressante
les poules piste monsieur cory zié
messieurs corrosive vous êtes depuis
1975 président des poules piste de
france 76 précisément oui et alors quel
est le but de votre association
c'est une excellente question je vous
remercie de me l'avoir posée là pfg te
dire l'association des bouddhistes de
france a été créé dans le but de mettre
en contact et de faire se rencontrer
aussi souvent que faire se peut les
françaises et les français qui aiment à
se mettre un poulpe sur la dette
et comment devient temps poule piste
excellente question
on devient poule piste on devient
propice pas par besoin d'identité par
besoin de se reconnaître soi même par
besoin de se reconnaître pour lutter
contre cette société et robotisée c'est
cela le monopole bis par besoin de ce
rock est alors en dehors de ce facteur
de reconnaissance quels sont les autres
avantages du poulpe isme c'est une
excellente question
ils sont ils sont vraiment multiples
voyez-vous par exemple l'été le poulpe
est frais et très agréable à porter en
revanche l'hiver il constitue un rempart
très très efficace contre toutes les
intempéries le froid la neige et puis
par ailleurs grâce à sa gluant ce
naturel le poulpe retient les pellicules
les pellicules disgracieuses dans la
prolifération sauvage pourrait nuire par
exemple au développement d'une idylle
mais on dit aussi que le poulpe isma des
effets bénéfiques sur la santé alors
qu'en est il exactement c'est une
excellente question je vous remercie de
me l'avoir posée c'est tout à fait exact
vous faites allusion j'imagine l'action
analgésiques du pool peace man 4
céphalées oui oui
alors si permis
les gens qui nous regardent ce soir
certains souffrent de maux de tête aux
migraines diverses qu'ils fassent
l'expérience suivante alors vous mettez
un poulpe sur la tête et vous absorbez
vous avez les deux aspirines et vous
verrez le résultat tout à fait
stupéfiant alors que si vous faites le
contraire
deux résultats nuls et puis alors enfin
le poulpe le poulpe est constitué un
excellent remède facile contre le bruit
oui vice-président et alors vous aussi
madame vous êtes poule piste depuis
toujours ou là là non vous allez rire
mais jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans j'étais
végétarienne authentique
puis j'ai rencontré georges l'un des
pionniers du poulpe isme et il vous a
converti non non il m'a toujours laissé
libre de mes opinions
sammonds lorsque nous allions au cinéma
ou bien au restaurant ou simplement
quand nous étions invités chez des amis
j'avais l'impression qu'il était un peu
triste d'être le seul apporter un plus
sur la tête
et puis l'idée que le jour du mariage
puisse arriver tête nue
je crois qu'il avait un petit peu honte
de moi j'ai cédé et vous ne le regrettez
pas c'est une excellente question je
vous remercie de leur poser je vais vous
dire je ne pourrais même pas supporter
l'idée que je puisse vivre sans un
poulpe sur la tête
mais quelle explication donnez-vous à
cela mais c'est un animal très
affectueux on s'y attache terriblement
très affectueux et très obéissants
regard des sultans pas bougé
ah ouais non c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
doucement sultan doucement voilà des
animaux d'où une association paisible et
pourtant les poules piste dérange
puisqu'on continue à leur refuser
l'entrée des plages alors à ce propos
écoutons ce qu'a à dire la présidente
des noms poule piste de france nous
disons que le spectacle de ces personnes
qui se promènent sur nos plages le
poulpe a l'air est un spectacle
révoltant pour nos enfants et même pour
les adultes
en conséquence de quoi nous demandons
aux municipalités du littoral de france
de bien vouloir nous montrer ce qu'elles
ont dans leur pantalon en leur
interdisant les bords de mer vous
comprenez pourquoi
devant cette intolérance qui frise
l'apartheid nous demandons nous
demandons quoi nous demandons instamment
aux pouvoirs publics de nous réserver
des espaces où nous pourrons enfin nous
et battre et poulpe est librement parce
que c'est un droit
et parce que nous l'exigeons salomé dieu
c'est un excellent poult je vous
remercie de m'avoir posé et bien nous
espérons que votre appel sera entendu
la semaine prochaine nous vous parlerons
d'une autre minorité agréable et
intéressante
les rhinos et rocistes à la semaine
prochaine
etonnant non
[Musique]